one thing's very clear in this data and
that is firms appreciate two things
number one they appreciate people who
have high ability shall we say people
who get good grades good test scores
other measures of ability the other
thing they appreciate is that you've had
some experience in their industry either
because you learned something or the
thing we're focusing on is that you've
reduced the uncertainty as to whether or
not you'd be a good fit in their
industry if you've never worked in the
industry that I'm hiring you to work in
before we don't know how well you're
gonna fit there so when I got hired into
academia they already knew I would fit
that pretty well because I'd been a grad
student and I'd been in school a long
time but they didn't know it for sure
and so over a period of time you figure
out hey this person can do research and
can teach and things like that it's that
type of thing and the more we see that
you've had experience doing that the
better sense we have that you will fit
in our industry let's consider two
applicants for a job they're both second
year MBA is applying for full-time jobs
at the same company holding everything
else equal if one of those candidates
has worked in that industry before their
odds of getting that job are more than
double that of the person who's never
worked in that industry in fact there
are about 2.4 times as high so just
taking you know as a baseline suppose
there's a company which accepts 10% of
its applicants that have never worked in
the industry before that same company
would accept a would make offers to
about 24% of the people who have worked
in that industry before so you can see
that's quite a dramatic difference it's
more than twice as likely to get the job
there's a very natural rent-to-own if
you will arrangement for MBAs which is
called the summer internship and it's
extremely useful for testing the waters
so an MBA who says hmm I'd really like
to work in investment banking but
they've never really worked in banking
they can by going to work in banking
over the summer they solve two problems
one they find out whether or not they
like work in banking and the other is a
bank might be very reluctant to hire
somebody who's never worked in
investment banking if they're gonna have
to go through a lot of effort to fire
them they fire them naturally at the end
of a summer internship there's a nice
natural breaking point in the employment
relationship now a lot of those people
get offers to come back and that's very
helpful in terms of making the market
work smoothly but if it doesn't work out
for some reason the firm isn't stuck
with a person that doesn't want which
can be very disruptive and expensive you
see that same thing where certainty with
where knowing that the person has
experience is valuable to that employer
but it's not quite as valuable because
they're more willing to take a chance on
the outsider because at the end of the
summer they can get rid of them for free
so in that in in the example there if we
have two applicants to a similar firm
for summer internships the the person
with experience in that industry is
about 1.8 times as likely to get the job
offer
whereas if it were a full-time job it's
well over 2 times closer to 2.4 times
we see a lot of people who get summer
internships get an offer to go back and
work there in our data it's about half
now a lot of the people who don't get
offers to come back that's for budgetary
reasons they go to a small company that
turns out not to have the ability to
hire the person back or something like
that but a lot of it if you look at
companies that have large numbers of
summer interns they're making offers to
maybe most of them but far from all of
them so firms and students are able to
take advantage of what they learn about
each other over the summer to get to
better matches the summer is very useful
both for learning about firms learning
about industries learning about each
other and so forth we see a lot of firms
make offers to the people that work
there over the summer we see a lot of
students go back to those firms but a
lot choose dot too so both sides of the
market are learning something both about
the mats they have with that firm and
how that compares to their outside
options that they then can go compare
that they can then go look at over the
next recruiting season the time to take
a chances in the summer people will take
a chance on you and your summer
internships much more than they will in
full-time jobs and you see more more at
least Stanford students I don't know
about other business schools as much
taking trying to split their time
between two internships over the summer
and especially if you want to try
something new that's a great idea as
long as each of those internships is
long enough for you to learn whether or
not this is the right place for you so
if a five-week internship is just enough
time to you know learn where your desk
is and you don't really get a great feel
for the industry then that's not gonna
solve the problem but if five weeks or
six weeks or Everlong a split internship
is is long enough to really learn about
that industry in that business then
splitting your summer up because it
gives you so many more options going
forward and so much more information
going forward